[Musik]
es ist ein plan wie nur behörden
ersinnen können
die hessische landeshauptstadt wiesbaden
in ihrer fußgängerzone aufhübschen und
hier in der hochstädter straße neues
granitpflaster verlegen
aber weil genau da eine großbaustelle
geplant ist soll das schicke neue
pflaster danach wieder zu geteert werden
schneider asphalt auf teuren pflaster
behörden ihr sinn gelder verschwendet
werden letztendlich das ist für mich ein
klassischer schildbürgerstreich
schwachsinns wie der typische bürokratie
die hochstetten straße passt so gar
nicht in die schicke wiesbadener
innenstadt
hier muss was passieren dachte man sich
im rathaus ein richtig hochwertiges
granitpflaster soll er kosten etwa
500.000 euro und das land zahlt auch
noch mindestens die hälfte aber an die
fetten fördertöpfe kommt man nur in das
pflaster spätestens 2018 liegt das
problem in der straße droht eine
großbaustelle
denn dieses theater soll demnächst
saniert werden
um nun an die subventionen zu kommen
wird die stadtverwaltung richtig kreativ
erst kommt das granitpflaster drauf und
damit der schwere baustellenverkehr
rollen kann werden später eine stoff
eine sand- und einer asphaltschicht
draufgepackt für knapp 18.000 euro so
der plan
diese konstruktion soll das pflaster
schützen heißt es von der stadt von der
ganzen aktion ist man im rathaus
felsenfest überzeugt schriftlich erklärt
man unsere einschätzung nach hat die
landeshauptstadt wiesbaden hier eine gut
koordinierte und verzahnte baumaßnahme
zum vorteil aller beteiligten nicht
zuletzt der stadtgesellschaft in
vorbereitung viele bürgerinnen und
bürger verstehen diesen bürokratischen
subventions irrsinn ganz und gar nicht
es ist totaler quatsch weil es macht
wirklich keinen sinn was schön zu machen
um es dann wieder nicht schön zu machen
ich denke es nicht besonders gut wenn
man
logische schritte umdreht um an geld zu
kommen ich finde es blödsinnig warum
macht man das nicht andersrum wäre doch
besser weil weder die ganzen schäden und
ganzen dreck auf der straße wie granit
auch ohne baustellenverkehr leiden kann
sieht man in den angrenzenden straßen
bei solchen schäden kann man nur hoffen
dass das neue granitpflaster und da es
falt- und schwerlastverkehr nicht
kaputtgeht sonst wird es noch mal
richtig teuer